nope
[Music]
that's a video that the panthers posted
and it indicates that a team that was
sitting at number 14 in round one was
trying to trade up to number eight the
vikings trying to make a move they
ultimately moved down from 14 to 23
they presumably got at 23 the guy they
would have taken at 14 but the guy they
wanted at 14
justin fields yeah
they were making that move up to number
eight if they could get it and it's not
like
they made a dramatic offer to move up
six no they tried and if and if the
panthers had said yes the name on the
card was going to be
fields comma
justin
ohio state
the
ohio state just to get it right yes on
the card yes and and think about it
think about it
for the way we reacted to kell and monde
being taken by the vikings at the top of
round three you multiply that by a
hundred that would have been the
reaction if the vikings trade up from 14
to eight to take justin fields given
that they still got kirk cousins under
contract for two more years at 56
million fully guaranteed calm down you
seem very giddy about all this relax i'm
okay i heard customers
this isn't just well he was the best guy
on the board
we want competition at back up
quarterback no they're thinking about
their next guy the fact that they tried
to get fields underscores that they are
evaluating kellen monde not just to be
the long-term backup but to be the guy
as soon as 2022. yeah i think that's the
big thing that it brings to the the
forefront here right like after the
draft when you and i we discussed a lot
you brought up like oh mon can be one of
those guys that replaces kirk cousins
he's only got two years left on his deal
all those things of course i agree i'm a
big fan of kellen monde and all of those
type of things no doubt but i think like
what the trade shows is that yeah
there's there's a real urgency obviously
to replace kirk cousins this wasn't like
a
third round pick with kellen monde i
think to go like well
he just got really good value on the
board let's draft him to draft him
because we can't pass up the value no
obviously there's a real thought and the
replacement of kirk cousins realizing
this is coming to an end and it they
don't want to be a part of you know
redoing it or extending it i think
that's basically what they're telling
you right there between the draft pick
of mond and now seeing that clip pretty
much says it all and i think it's also
interesting of course that he's in the
division now and minnesota's gonna have
to deal with them as being the
quarterback of the chicago bears but
i think more than anything mike you're
kind of spot on and what what i thought
of it kind of telling us more about
i think what minnesota thinks of kirk
cousins at this point more than anything
you know and it's also cool that of
course they like justin fields too
well and i think what underpins all of
this and it's not that the vikings are
ever going to share these details but
kirk cousins contract had a clause that
kicked in a fully guaranteed salary for
next year of 35 million this year it's
21. it would have been an opportune time
to extend the contract to come up with
something that worked it gave them cap
relief so they could do more in free
agency it just felt like the planets
were aligned
for something to be done
to replace the contract that runs
through 2022. and i asked what happened
super bowl week right
here when i i threw it out there hey is
this something you'd be inclined to
consider you know salary cap and all
that stuff he says honestly i just
signed the extension last offseason it
really doesn't kick in until this coming
year it's a two-year deal those two
years begin with 2021. i think it's more
about going out there next season and
the year after that and playing at a
high enough level that would justify
being able to do another deal behind
that that is a very tactful and
diplomatic way of giving a middle finger
to the vikings and saying no new
contract i hold the cards i'm going to
do to you what i did to washington well
what the vikings aren't going to do in
response to that is have themselves in a
position where colt mccoy is their plan
b they're going to go out and get a
better plan b who may become their plan
a
and that that's where
kirk cousins may have flown too close to
the sun that's right pastrami right and
got the vikings to say we got to start
looking for other options because this
guy isn't going to play our game we got
to find someone who will yeah that's
right and then listen you know kirk
cousins who's really good he's not good
enough to play this game to where teams
are going to go like oh okay
all right gosh you're a superstar we'll
just we'll put everything down and we'll
wait for you to get more leverage to
leverage us for more money i mean that's
that's basically what he told you and
that's basically what it is um i got two
years i haven't leveraged them enough
yet to talk about the the new contract
you know so we're not talking about it
i'm good with where it is right now okay
yeah i don't blame minnesota you know
they're they're gonna move on kirk
cousins is real good we know you can win
games but as you described before
uh he's not the type of guy that's going
to always be able to carry a team on his
back or when the offense is not hitting
on all cylinders the kind of guy that
can like physically do things
off schedule to help the team out that
way and i would argue that guys like
kellen mott and justin fields actually
have more potential to do those type of
things so yeah it's uh it's it's
interesting but i think minnesota is
basically telling us that this is the
last two years of kirk cousins and uh
we'll see you later they they basically
mike just went like this they just
plucked it off and went we love you not
we'll see you two years from now
but but but i still think they're all in
with them this year definitely right
next year is when it becomes interesting
can they find someone who would take the
35 million fully guaranteed salary off
their hands are off the table some of it
49ers are off the table right exactly
exactly washington's off the table yeah
but would they presumably but but but
will they find a landing spot if they
decide to shift from him to kalamata
could it be that kirk cousins is just
the highest paid backup quarterback in
nfl history at 35 million next year if
they go with mon who would be among the
lowest paid and for anyone who's
confused here's
here's why the cousin's statement was so
impactful in my view
if he plays out the next two years
the vikings have no way to hold him in
place for 23 what about the franchise
tag hear about the franchise tag his cap
number next year 2022 is 45 million
because he was tagged twice by
washington he gets a 44 raise if the
vikings tag him even once that's 64.8
million that's the franchise tag number
for kirk cousins in 2023. it so the only
way you're going to keep him then is if
you're the highest bidder on the open
market you've got no protection what
kind of plan is that for the vikings oh
cousins is our guy the next two years
and then if he plays well enough we'll
extend it
we're going to be in competition with
anyone else out there who wants to sign
it yeah no 2018 all over again we can't
have that no you can't have that you
leave yourself in a bad spot they they
bought themselves insurance
you know for no matter you know what
happens we'll see where it goes but you
know yeah they're not going to play this
game with kirk cousins and have him have
all the leverage and power over their
organization to where they have to deal
with that and that becomes the main
talking point yeah they have something
i guess the bottom line is at the end of
the day what's going on in minnesota is
no different than what's going on in
green bay it really isn't the vikings
have gone out and drafted the guy that
they hope will develop into the
replacement for kirk cousins and the
vikings are saying through their actions
and throwing the through the effort to
try to get justin fields that they're
ready to move on yeah and kirk cousins
gonna have to change their mind if if
that's the case and because of what's
happened chris cousins can have two
great years
and then
by then he'll he'll have all the power
and he'll walk away yeah that's the
thing this this relationship is not
lasting more than two years no matter
how it goes the next two seasons i don't
think so i think they basically told you
no matter how it goes the next two
seasons they don't view him as the guy
to be the guy of the future get them
over the hump or whatever i think that's
quietly what's kind of being said here
it's like yeah even if we think he kills
it the next two years it's not going to
be that to the point of where we're
going to be like oh we got to have him
back we got to pay him top dollar
they're basically going i think what
you're saying mike two years and done
and you're right it's similar to green
bay except there's just you know this
one tiny difference that kirk cousins is
not aaron rodgers
yeah just a slight difference in the
player just a slight and it wasn't a
first-round pick and a trade-up and all
that type of stuff too but no your
point's real you're right i mean i think
there's there's some writing on the wall
here for for
but if if this gesture
operates as the red hot poker that turns
kirk cousins into the mvp it will have
been worth it although i would not bet
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports